all right boys we got BS
[Applause]
JoJo final game of the 2023 NHL Global series
aichi Arena another sold out crowd here in
beautiful Stockholm Suite now please welcome
the Toronto Maple leagues and the Minnesota
Wild Stockholm has been the host of the
most games outside of North America of
course Swedish players really making impact
in the NHL last couple of decades ceremonial
puck drop out at Center Ice featuring
mattz sundine Lea's Legend great Swedish
player let go white go here come on here boys hey
Buzz okay stay back here please okay
let me bring it out pause here we
go listen up I want Hardy
moose Patty I got one I got
one no stick one's got no stick car is
off the goal post and stayed out it was
loose behind Flur but Tiano couldn't
poke at home while getting some Puck
Lo did not put that in [Applause] got away
with one there toell tip free Mar shot he
scores it's his first of the year and the
wild have taken a one- nothing [Applause]
lead hey they're cheating
walls if you guys get them
just in the the ozone like if you
guys have you guys kind of get in
trouble here's kander pass in and deflection
they score Austin Matthews to tie the game at
one job better sticks boys better sticks turn
turn turn head nice play w in partner across
nice shoot scores Matthew KN gives Toronto
the lead lead the rush you what a pass
[Music] dude hum humm hum hum here we
go three a forward over
here get up get
up time time time time time there you
go throw everything to the slot hey hey Stay Stay
Stay Stay Stay Stay Stay de coming every time boys
hey we know it we know it quickly to Rossy and
now Matt suell open in front capris off backand
forehead wall the sa with his right P Capri off
just couldn't lift it over the right pad of Joseph
wall hey we're done now we're done Johnny it's
gotten awfully spicy here at the horn ending the
[Music]
second Matthews far Corner into
the slot area quick shot by Ry
scor and the AES have their first two
goal lead keep shooting green shoot
pu Middleton High slot droing
one he scores Jake Middleton and
610 into the third the wild pull
closer they're down three to two
boys
broin hand on favor walking in right
side got pass to check who wanted for
this go zarell in front of the net on
the Wild app P even here in Stockholm
and this game will be decided Beyond
regulation as we head to overtime I
think every game we've had here we've had
a comeback y I got D I got broin I got the
D oh look out oh all right I got him all right
Bergie it back to Bro into the corner green May
P Sur him Eric conect to a loose puck in front
turn and shot W made the save rebound stabed
up Ro hurry one that's blocked Johansson charge
his way got pass the check he's got BR in front
Johansson with a rer blocked by the sliding Morgan
Riley picked up by nander in with tarz William
naner on Johanson defending in comes neander
scores William beer puts an exclamation point
on a brilliant week in Stockholm holy Ma and
all Willie have a trip to Sweden the Lea wi it
all [Applause] return hey guys way to go everyone
to say it's pretty fitting into the whole we own
job where could you have written a more story
book ending for your two games over here I mean
it was uh pretty special for sure to get that uh
OT winner there just playing the games and being
with my family and showing the guys stock them
I think those three things were special a lot of
fun city was great um atmosphere was great you
know I think it was just a cool kind of little
experience that uh you got to enjoy with your
teammates four points on this trip okay four
important points find ways to get the job done
that feels good going home B and that thing else
get out of here great trip boys uh MO uh tone
PK great job tonight but this guy runs this city
[Applause] man go home keep this thing
[Applause]
going